record this session so that we can share
it
um so just in terms of
kicking it off um i
think it would be interesting to hear
from each of you
a little bit about why you joined in
today
you can i prefer that we have a
interactive dialogue but if you want to
use a chat
certainly won't have a problem with that
but
if you can just give me a quick blurb
about why you signed up for this today
that would be helpful
okay this is gustavo i can start
okay so
i'm currently i currently have a
leadership
role i'm for six months i'm leading a
team of engineers and
i'm very interested in this topic i want
to develop more of my career
and so that's why i'm here
i'm about to change careers also
so i'm trying to to learn more and
getting ready for my next next step
great what what are you changing too
uh i'm actually uh my contract is
uh about to to end okay
so uh i'm starting to
look for new jobs new positions so
applying to some jobs
great great okay um
thank you for sharing gustavo appreciate
it anybody else care to share why they
signed up today
yeah sure i can uh share with you so i'm
currently working as a data scientist
but uh it's been a while since i'm
working in this role like for
almost five years and i'm looking
forward in the next couple of years to
move to a
uh like a manager or a leadership role
okay and i'm look for actually the vice
versa part
so developing like leadership skills
uh which are like more technical
managerial roles so technical leader
roles okay so great okay well we're
going to certainly talk about that today
edwin did you want to share
yes sure well so let me see
um well i've been in leadership role
uh before as a leader for
uh an engineering team for a couple of
years
and uh when i got into the position i
realized that
uh you know things that
made me sick successful as an engineer
before were not exactly the skills that
i needed
for the leadership position so it's a
learning experience
and since that moment i realized that
this is a field in which i needed to
learn and grow more
at this point i'm not i'm not currently
in leadership position because i changed
jobs recently
but i decided that i didn't want to you
know get into
that same scenario in the future without
you know having invested in getting
better at it before i get there
so um i'm trying to capitalize on the
knowledge that i acquired during that
short experience and at the same time
you know
get more um you know more more
information
more knowledge that i can use for the
future when hopefully i i get to be that
position again
hey excellent thank you and and you're
right so
almost always people are promoted
we are promoted or moved into leadership
roles often because
we are viewed as um very or
the most technically competent and so it
is a
an eye-opening experience for some of us
to realize hey as you said the things
that got me here
are not the things that will keep me
here and make me the best leader
so that's why we're going to talk about
this today so thank you all for sharing
i'm surprised we don't have more
participants but that's okay i
um this will be a great small group to
talk with and then we'll share it
with others but um anyway so let's move
on to
um to the um
a little bit about me i'm not gonna you
can read this so i'm not gonna go
through it i um was in a leadership role
for um let's see when did i start a
leadership role
so in a leadership role for about 17
years of formal leadership role i would
consider myself to have been a leader
an informal leader which i'm sure most
of you
have had that experience prior to that
i led an hr team at a high level and
in some ways what we're going to talk
about today with tech positions
is not different than any kind of
technical competence in any particular
field such as human resources
or marketing um the same
um principles apply in my opinion
to the leadership aspects of the job um
i would say that my uh
my background was similar to what edwin
described i tried to do my very best
work as an individual contributor
i learned a lot of skills in hr
and learned different skills and i
believe that to some degree
that was why i found myself in a
leadership
role and um and then when i got in a
leadership role
um i started to realize a number of
things and we're going to talk about
that and
in some ways um just as you said edwin
i too learned firsthand that the things
that got me there
didn't um weren't going to be the skills
that i needed going forward and so it
took me a little while to figure that
out
um i have had some experience
supervising a technical team at a high
level
by the way uh vinica vincius um
if i said that right thank you for
joining us um
i in my human resources
oversight we had a human resources
information systems team
i actually started my individual
contributor career at northern arizona
university
as a what i would consider a data
analyst role
we are implementing a human resources
information system so i did have some
experience
actually doing that work and that did
serve me pretty well from an
understanding
standpoint anyway we're going to move on
i don't want to spend the whole time
talking about that
but um that just gives you a little bit
about where i come from
and um we're not going to spend a lot of
time
on the agenda we're going to just the
basics
talk about um this topic
uh the technical skill uh development
leadership
skills what the workplace needs are and
so anyway we'll move on
we'll move through this pretty quickly
um
okay so tell me what you think just to
get us started
about what is the value of developing
and right now i'm going to
focus on technical skills in a technical
leadership role
and i will say one thing that one of the
reasons i chose this topic
is this is common for udacity students i
get this pretty often
um they're really uh
struggling with the question about how
deep and broad their technical skills
need to be
maybe they're already in a leadership
role or they aspire to be in a
leadership role
so tell me what you think about
technical skills in a technical
leadership role
well i think that um
if you're in a in a leadership role
most likely you you you will have to
make decisions
or solve so you know conflicts when it
comes to making decisions maybe by other
people in the team
and so it's fundamental that you have
some experience and that you also have
technical skills that helps you
understand you know technical problems
the team is dealing with
and uh and and that will help you
also make you the best decisions
and to solve conflicts uh you know
within the team
right yeah it's a little hard
particularly in this
field i think to oversee a unit
if you had no um technical skills
um because it is so complex having a
broad at least a broad understanding and
maybe some deep
competence in a particular um
language or technical area can help you
um as you said um resolve issues because
that is one role of a leader
uh anyone else from the participant
group want to share
what you think about the value of
technical skills in a in a
technical leadership role
[Music]
i would love to hear your voice at least
if you would like if you would care to
just say hi
and and maybe weigh in on this you don't
have to but
we're we we have a small group so having
this be interactive will work best
hey hello people hi how are you
i'm denise i'm a
business analyst
and actually i'm working right now so
it will be a little hard to be to me to
be interactive
because i'm following up with two things
at the same time
okay okay you're multitasking
it sounds like or trying to do that
yes trying to i think no one can do this
very well
right sometimes try yeah
yeah i hear ya okay okay well thank you
for introducing yourself okay all right
so just
moving on if you have um you know
thoughts about this
let's go ahead and um talk about that
but i think really to develop this
conversation
further um maybe we frame uh the next
question
uh this way in what ways do leaders of
technical teams
best serve their teams and i'd like you
to think about
um leaders that you've had
in your experience people you've worked
for or maybe alongside of who either
served in a technical lead
role or some kind of leadership role and
think about what the important quality
qualities and competencies
were that they had that made them either
a really great leader or a good leader
or a not so good leader
what was most effective in supporting
the team and what things
did you look at and say oh if i ever
become
a leader or if someone ever puts me in
charge i'm not going to do that
so thoughts about that
assuming that you have you know a
healthy team i believe that
something that i admire uh in leaders
and
and that i aspire also to be is
the kind of leader that gets the best
out of everyone in the team
like uh you know every one of the
members of the team you know what they
are
what they you know looking to accomplish
and
areas in which they would like to get
better and you give them the opportunity
to
develop and to prove themselves and
like every one of us in the team
individually could say
at the end of the year that we got
better as the result of the work that we
have been doing together
so um something that i really like and
admire in leaders that i have had in the
past as well
is that supportive environment where
they're really concerned about
um you know developing their the skills
of their own team and
and that everyone feels like they had a
contribution
in a way i think everyone is looking to
accomplish that
right like we we're in we're doing a job
you know
but but at the same time every one of us
is looking to
you know get better at something that's
perhaps one of the reasons we're here as
well
so individually all of us have an agenda
and uh the job that we do for a company
is a way also
to accomplish that great thank you for
sharing that edwin that's great
others gustavo
yes i i i agree with edwin
about uh developing the team yeah
everyone wants to have the opportunity
to to do the work and
present ideas and get support from
from the leader for these ideas
i think this is a leader that allows
people to
to find solutions to propose solutions
that
wants to to listen and give
right maybe a
also suggests a different path if if
it's better but
i think it's a leader that listens to
the team and is open to
two different opinions is very important
i i admire
leaders that even uh endorse
the the the the
uh the employee that okay go ahead do
and i will support you
no matter uh
no matter what so i uh that's uh one
one experience i had with the leader
that he said
you take the decision and even if i
disagree i will support you
that's awesome yeah that was awesome
yeah yeah that some key things i heard
in what you said
listening and actually have that on my
list to talk about later on that
so important it's not just hearing but
really active listening and
as you said having the courage a leader
having the courage
to support someone and encourage them to
as you said develop their own skills
make decisions
uh support for that educated risk taking
that is so often missing i mean
particularly on technical teams you've
got a lot of creativity
you've got people with um aspirations of
being innovative
and the last thing you want to do is not
you know
not be a leader that supports or be a
leader that doesn't support risk taking
that's so important that's how things
get better
and as you said um you know that leader
that
that helped you with that really in a
genuine way
communicated their support for you even
if they had a different thought
and that is one of the very important
things about
leadership and i actually learned that
um very late in my career
when i learned coaching um asking
empowering questions which is
is one of the key coaching skills um as
opposed to telling people what they need
to be doing
um you know as experts and and
you know we talked earlier about people
being moved into leadership roles
because they were
you know they're technically very
competent sometimes that's all we know
how to do it first as leaders
we know how we would approach something
and
um you know gustavo what you said is so
important
becoming a leader that has the courage
to let their
staff shine and take charge and make
decisions on their own
that's how they grow and develop
themselves so
it's so important to learn how to stop
telling
people what to do and how to ask those
open-ended
empowering questions that will help you
know support people making their own
decisions
great other thoughts
i think one of the key roles is also to
do
something like business problem
translation to
technical terms and making it more clear
for your team
i'm not sure if it's if it's the right
role for the i mean
right job for the leader but it's also
very important
to do this translation because sometimes
as you said uh technical teams want to
be creative but sometimes
lose track of what is the exact goal
that they should be focusing on
right so right well and absolutely
i think you know um you know
and really that kind of speaks to what
soft skill
what's the soft skill that um that that
falls into as you're translating what
are you doing with your team
communicating and communicating with
clarity right
you yeah helping frame the
the situation in language that everyone
can
understand so if you don't have those
technical skills it's a little difficult
to do that
um and and you know it can be done
if if you're if you don't have an
understanding
of that particular technical area then
how would you solve that issue
let's say there was a particular
technical problem
somebody else on your team was had more
expertise
and clarity you needed to bring clarity
to the situation
what do you think would be the best
approach
um i think uh if i'm not knowledgeable
enough then i'll
let the senior person take charge and
explain it to the team
so i mean that's what i think yeah
that's excellent and so many um leaders
have difficulty letting go and doing
that
um and so i i think that
that's the challenge is to get
comfortable
letting others take the lead letting
others show their expertise
i don't know if any of you participated
in the recent webinar i think jackie did
one on the imposter syndrome
and i didn't watch it but you know
as a leader i think sometimes we think
we have to be the ship
you know smartest person in the room we
have to have all the answers
and it's so freeing when we discover and
hopefully we discover it early enough
that we let go of that role and we say
you know
no my job is here to be a facilitator a
leader
a support person to serve my employees
in the way they need me to serve them
best
i think edwin said it earlier to know
what each person needs and then to let
go
of the fact that we will not always have
the answers
and that really can challenge some of us
um self-included so but it's very
freeing and i know that from personal
experience that when i learned to let go
of the reins and let others take charge
and show their expertise
not only did i build a stronger
commitment with my team i think
but it made my job a lot easier i had a
lot more fun
so anyway other side
something else yeah i wanted to mention
that
something else i well that i i
think it works or at least it worked for
me it's like
um i like to make every make sure that
everyone
for example at the start of the quarter
make sure everyone in the team
is very clear on the objectives of the
quarter for example
and i i would go to a 101 and ask
do you have the objectives of the
quarter clear and do you know the role
that you're going to play
in this quarter and the person would say
yes i understand
or they would say no i don't so let's
talk about that and so
that is really helpful in a sense that
now
i could let go of responsibility because
i have a technical team
maybe they know the answer maybe they
don't know but i i
but i know they know that north is in
this direction so i don't know how we're
going to get there
you guys are supposed to you know help
us get there i don't know all the
answers
you every one of you have an assignment
and you have to go investigate and come
up with ideas and maybe we can discuss
them but
i don't have to be you know constantly
telling them what
to do if they know where we're supposed
to get
uh to get to yeah that's that's
wonderful you know you're
what you're doing is clarify not only
clarifying
understanding but you're communicating
um
in a concrete way the expectations right
so you're remo
removing as much ambiguity as possible
which really is the role of a great
leader
is to really make sure everyone's on the
same page
so thank you for sharing that that's so
important other thoughts
so what might be i want to move on to
another this has been great conversation
i want to move on to another question
before we leave this slide
what might be a reason or a unique
situation where
um a leader really needs to have some
deep
technical skills in a certain area
any circumstances might
create that situation
um well i think there are a few things
that i can
i can think that has been like my
experience okay
one has one aspect is that sometimes
there
the leader needs to represent the team
and and when he is in a meeting with you
know business people
or you know he has to make a decision
before
um the per the people he is he's he or
she has represented the team
uh for um he may need some technical
skills and knowledge of you know how
difficult it is to accomplish tasks
questions like how long this is going to
take and
there is even a moral responsibility
sometimes when he's making that kind of
decisions like if you go to a meeting
and
they are pressuring you to have
something ready for one week and you
know it's not possible
you're even making a moral decision
there you could be compromising the
lives of your team
and things like that so having a good
understanding of the complexity of a
problem
and and you know whether it is possible
to
do it in certain amount of time um it's
key
and and and then also when having
discussions with the team
like you were saying before it is not
the case that
every time the team agrees with the way
you think the problem needs to be solved
and so it requires like for example if
you know
that your idea is the right way to solve
the problem so you have to be ready to
have an open discussion
and like if the team it's you know
adamant that that is not the way you
have to kind of be ready to
take them to the place where you are and
that is that is not easy
like uh you can you have to be ready to
ask difficult questions and
eventually even decide whether you were
right or wrong
um but you require certain understanding
of the
technical aspects to have that
discussion right
and and i think particularly in leading
a technical team the kind of technical
team that we're talking about that
you know students are studying those
kinds of courses at udacity
um you know often times i i mean i agree
with everything you're saying
oftentimes i run into the student who's
maybe early in their career
and really thinks that before they can
go for the leadership role they really
need to
know all the languages or know you know
have deep
skills in all the particular areas of
artificial intelligence or something
like that
and one of the things i encourage them
to think about
is having high level exposure um
even as you described edwin you know
decision making
and representing the team um
even having a high level understanding
of you know the full scope of what you
supervise
but not having deep understanding in all
the particular areas
you can be very effective um at least
that's my opinion
especially if as needy said
how you use your resources letting
others if you're
you know if you need more expertise you
can rely on one of your team
um i think so anyway any thoughts on
that
yeah i would say depending also on the
team uh
profile right if if most of the team
are less experienced
engineers let's say and uh then the
leader would be
would need to to have strong technical
skills to
to lead the team right and also to give
orientation
and uh share his experience so i think
in this scenario
uh also the leader will need uh
strong tactical skills and depends also
on the
how the company is structured right the
leadership
uh i think in line with what edwin said
some companies require the
team leaders to have strong technical
skills
and not only the required soft skills
for leadership
absolutely the profile of the team the
company structure
the size of the team right you have a
small
team small organization the leader may
actually play an individual contributor
role in addition to their leadership
role
so i think that's why i said in the
introduction to this session you know it
really depends
and um you know we need to be prepared
for any situation but
in general i think really developing
your soft skills as
as a leader will serve you best and then
you already know you have the technical
confidence to jump in and learn what you
need to learn
in a pinch or find figure out a resource
you know to serve that role so
thank you for sharing that gustav i
think that's absolutely right the
company structure
team size the makeup of the team
the roles and responsibilities may
dictate
um how much or how deep
um the leader's technical skills need to
be so
okay so i wanted to share with you um
a study that
was conducted actually looks
like about seven years ago by an
organizational
development company called blessing
white
and um the things that they i've put on
the slide here the things that they have
um identified as
what the workplace needs of technical
people are are listed here the six
critical things anything surprise you
i guess maybe what is collegial
collegial support support
and sharing um
creating an environment um such that you
know
technical people feel safe to share
their
you know sharing information with each
other
um a safe environment um
a manager who deal in my mind that's a
manager a leader who deals with
conflict rapidly um you know if you have
interpersonal conflict you want to take
care of that
um early on so it doesn't become a
detractor from
the team moving forward together and
getting along and being comfortable
sharing with it with other
walking the talk as far sharing
information
not being territorial with information
or expertise
demonstrating you know i guess as a
leader i would demonstrate that one of
my expectations is that we all share
information with each other we help each
other be successful
it's not about competition it's about
collaboration those are my thoughts
others have thoughts that's a really
good question edwin asked
anyone else
i'm a bit confused about the
professional identification
so what does this really mean okay
so um um in terms of
of their study what i read was that
um people in technical these kinds of
technical fields
have a high degree of place a high
degree of value
on their own professional identification
being seen as an
expert being seen as competent
being allowed to be creative and
innovative
and so um what they
thrive under is a leadership style um
that really provides the kind of support
that we've been talking about so far
today
um you know if you've ever worked in a
situation
have you ever worked in a situation
where your manager was competing with
you
for with their own expertise
i hope not but it can happen but it can
happen yeah
so i i've seen managers sometimes
looking
up and not looking down meaning not
focusing on their team enough but
focusing on what their managers want
from them
that kind of i don't know where to put
that in
in this bullet points but
yeah i mean i've seen that happening and
that makes the team suffer a lot because
they promise too much and then the team
suffers
right well and maybe we could probably
put it in a couple categories in my own
thought process that you're right that
that happens
achievement might be if you have a
leader who's
who is um you know very achievement
focused and many of us are
or we wouldn't be in a leadership role
but the trick
is to find the balance the balance
between not selling your team out
and um you know making reasonable
commitments
involving the team and what's possible
and having those discussions early on
and realizing that you can only push
people so far
and you know what and also being there
to support them
so i think what you say is very
important meeting
um we need to make sure that um
as leaders that we aren't selling our
team out we're not
that we're not so focused on our own
credit and achievement that we
lose sight of who's doing the work um
and again being um maybe back to the
support piece being a leader who
accepts responsibility and even takes
blame when it's needed
and but is always focused on giving
credit
to the team or the the folks on the team
who deserve the credit
um yeah what do you think
it's okay i'll read one paragraph from
that study you can look this up if
you're interested but
one one of the paragraphs that kind of
summarized this
the points on the slide was such
technical people
tend to fit specific criteria such as
advanced degrees and specific roles or
functions
for the purpose of organizational
development though
what unites them as a specific
population
these are the six key workplace needs
that must be addressed
for them to thrive so that's kind of the
context for this this list
okay any other
comments or thoughts on this
i have one more article i can share
about this
but i want to make sure you get a chance
to weigh in on this if you have thoughts
i want to comment on something that
nidi mentioned a moment ago when
she said for example um leaders who
just you know want to
to do the things only for their own
benefit and not
for the benefit of the team and i think
the problem that i have
noticed even in organizations that have
good
leaders is that leaders are most of the
time evaluated by the results that their
team
produce and not by their leadership
skills
so something that i used to tell my
manager is
why my okrs or my objectives are only
about
delivering these or that result and not
are about
how much did you develop your people how
motivated is your team
um and you know and how well are you
communicating
objectives or how well are things
working on your team right
right none of those none of those things
are part of the
okrs or objectives that leader has to
um you know deliver at the end of the
quarter
not none of those things are your
evaluation your evaluation is
was the project delivered on time and
nobody cares nobody cares how you
delivered on time
and so i i really find that that it's a
a serious serious problem in uh probably
in the industry and everywhere else
yeah and it's a it's rare to find an
organization where
leaders are evaluated for you know their
execution
of their leadership role and for the
development and
and you know exercise of their
leadership skills and not for the
results that the team
is at the end delivering and so i think
that's a mistake
and that creates this kind of leaders
where they are only looking for
themselves and not for the team because
that will be the wrong kind of leader
you're absolutely right and
unfortunately this becomes
something that's perpetuated upward
through upward and downward throughout
an organization
if they get it right the whole
organization
can be in great shape if they have
leaders at all levels who understand
the concept of what you just said and
unfortunately so many people do not
or they become a roadblock to that and
so
this is um this is a key organizational
issue um it's about the measurement
criteria
uh we are so focused on bottom line
results
that so many times um we get we forget
about what's really important
and and the things that in my mind
what you said was spot on and it's about
sustaining the organization and the
ability to
deliver results long-term if you don't
pay attention
to supporting the team and
the leadership skills of all of your
leaders even developing good leadership
skills on your with your individual
contributors is important we're going to
talk about that
a little bit um then you're lost and
your ability to sustain that
organization long term
and keep your people happy and support
their
development um
that becomes a real struggle other
thoughts on this
thank you for bringing that up i want to
work for you in my next life edwin
[Laughter]
thank you that's uh right to here yeah
if you find a company like that edwin
and
i'll send you my resume also yeah
well you all have great thoughts on this
i i suspect you're
all either great leaders already um even
if you don't have the formal role but i
know that a couple of you at least are
doing that kind of role now
one other thing i want to share and
there's a citation at the end of this
presentation
for harvard business review they have
great
leadership articles so i highly suggest
that if you have an interest in this
topic
that you read those articles but i
found a particular statement that
kind of speaks to what we've been
talking about today clever people
want a high degree of organizational
protection
and recognition that their ideas are
important
needy maybe this gets to the
professional identification a little bit
they also demand the freedom to explore
and fail
this is similar to what was mentioned
earlier about the risk-taking
they expect their leaders to be
intellectually
on their plane but they do not want a
leader's talent
and skills to outshine their own
that i thought really kind of
encapsulated the whole professional
identification piece that last part
thoughts or comments on this
i have seen really really
unhealthy
i don't know if call it a culture
where where there you know there's this
this culture of
finger pointing when somebody makes a
mistake
the rest want to know who made a mistake
and
and it it it's just like um
so unhealthy for for for the team
that that happens and so i think like
something that
um i believe that has been really um
uh useful is the you know the opposite
way of thinking
like the realization that you typically
never get to the right answer
uh the first time and you're gonna make
mistakes and
making those mistakes are okay provided
that you don't repeat them over and over
right
right and and so and so
that kind of creates this safe
environment
where you can say what you're thinking
and you can go and try
ideas and find that find out if those
ideas are working and
maybe build on top of those ideas so i
think that's um
that's great and i have have seen that
works but
much better than the opposite because i
have seen i have leave the the two
the two sides of the coin all right
so that that's that's great and and it
you know it really kind of speaks to how
important the soft skills
are in a leadership role um and i
appreciate you
um providing that insight um in some
ways it also addresses that bullet
collegial support it addresses many of
those areas that the blessing white
study
uncovered so thank you for that
um so it as an individual contributor
let's let's talk about the kind of the
reverse question
um what's important for an individual
contributor say you know what are the
soft skills or the leadership skills
that are important we're just going to
hit this pretty quickly because i want
to talk about developing
leadership skills before we leave the
session
but what are your thoughts around this
what are the typical
viewer hiring an individual contributor
someone who's not in a formal leadership
role
what kinds of soft skills would you look
for
i think we we're talking about oh go
ahead midi
oh it's okay you go ahead
okay so uh i think it's still
communication at least
[Music]
where where i work we still hire people
who are able to kind of translate their
contributions
in a language which is uh more
understandable for the leader if he's
not very technical
and still able to get the gist or the
mean message across and
individual and i think also like
communication still but speaking their
mind
what they think uh not holding
themselves back
and also uh this group
uh so team skills so able to work with
other people
to understand your individual
contributor but you still
cannot survive on your own you need your
team around you
great those are three great ones yeah
okay communicating and speaking directly
being you know having the courage of
conviction to speak from your heart
in your head right um what you really
feel and what you really think
okay gustavo please add to that
so yes about this collaborative
collaborative work
so a leader when he becomes a leader he
he cannot think only
about himself right he's thinking about
the team so i think
this in an individual contributor is
also very important
that he's also thinking about the team
and how he can
help and support the team not only
getting his
job done i i i really like
this environment where people are
collaborating and
helping each other i think this is a
very very good environment
right even if if you never aspire to
become a leader the best thing you can
do to support the team and yourself
honestly
is is to help you know take
uh take an active role in helping others
be successful there's plenty of credit
to go around
in the right organization
i you know the ideal organization being
one like edwin described where
everyone feels supported and people get
along and there's not this competition
um but that and and so you can see where
that that is really the job of the
leader but
absolutely an individual contributor
role those team skills
um being able to collaborate with others
and you know problem solving is another
particular area and that collaboration
is key to that
um any other um
leadership skills that you think that
individual contributors need to have
i i think that something that i find
really helpful
is that um you know members of the team
are
you know independent thinkers that um
because is um israel
like i was saying before it's rarely the
case that leader has all the answers
and and in particularly in
in this industry you face problems that
you
have not faced before as a team and
you don't know how you're going to solve
them so you need you need the help of
the team
and you don't want people in your team
that maybe are really good
technically speaking but they never
speak your their never speak their minds
you don't know what they are thinking
um and so i i rather have people on the
team that are independent thinkers that
like to challenge ideas or that at least
would like to contribute on the ideas
that others have said and things like
that
i think that's fundamental for for the
team to work well
and um there is a phrase
in spanish i don't know how to say it in
english but it's something like it's
i rather like people that i have to
contain
than people that i have to be constantly
you know spurring on or you know trying
to
you know get into action so
that's that's that's better so i think
that that's something that i believe
is uh fundamental right right people not
afraid as
as you and needy both said
um you know that will speak their mind
their independent thinkers
um really important in a lot of key
areas conflict resolution problem
solving
um thank you great great items to add to
the list
a couple two others that i'd like to add
include resiliency and adaptability i
think that
um so many times the things that get in
the way
of people being successful is their
resistance to change and new ideas or
not being resilient to bounce back from
things that maybe
um become a a little bit of
inhibitor or that adaptability to change
is really important
for both individual contributors and
leaders and then project management and
good time management skill are a couple
i'll just throw in
at the end we don't need to really
discuss those but
um anyway okay thank you all for that
that's great
all right so let's get to the kind of
the meat of the matter and i want to
know
what your thoughts are on how to develop
leadership
skills and what's nice about this
conversation is we've identified some
high-level
leadership skills that are really
important and we've also
talked about what's important as a an
individual contributor and there is
definitely some overlap
the breadth and depth might be different
but there's definitely some overlap so
that puts people
who will hone their soft skills and
individual
contributor roles it really puts them in
the
in the place of being able to advance
if they develop those well if they have
that
aspiration and so i think there's
quite a bit of overlap here in what
we're talking about
but the how-to is the is the big
question and i have some answers but i'd
like to hear if anyone
and let's just maybe weigh in with a
couple of quick thoughts on
what's the best way to develop these
maybe mentor somebody act as a mentor
for your fellow
colleague who's a bit junior to you
maybe
and people who can take interns perhaps
i mean
there are options but i i mean put
yourself
in those shoes for a while find someone
who does this
well and learn all you can about them
and as you say maybe request
that you have a formal mentorship
arrangement with that person
that's an excellent idea that you bring
up about the mentorship and that is
different than a coach
a mentor is somebody who works in the
field who
has the skills you aspire to have
that is willing to lead you through kind
of how they develop that
it's not to say that that's the only way
to develop that for yourself
but a mentor is different than a coach
in this way
gustavo
so i think that the best is to try to
develop the skills before you become a
leader right
so while you are contributing a team
you you identify the skills you want to
develop and you try to develop them
while you are individual contributor
so you can be a leader without the
formal position
uh so i think that's the
good approach on how on how to develop
okay great yeah you know having the
foresight to start working on this early
um but then you know it take i mean it
can take a lifetime to really
learn all of those skills and um
we each have strengths and things that
we're not so strong at
so really getting committed to
knowing where your strengths are and
sometimes learning to develop those
areas that you might consider a weakness
although sometimes you just hire
a person to work with you to fill that
gap
and they become a consultant for you
we're not all good at
all things and that can be another
approach
you can get better but we may not be the
best at certain things and so
hiring um to fill that gap um as long as
you listen to that person
and you you know use their expertise can
be
really beneficial if you have a gap as a
leader
okay yeah i think it's it's chaos right
to
to to know that you you don't know
everything that you will
never be good at everything so
i think knowing that is also very
important to
to keep developing and keep growing
[Music]
yeah we can we always learn right during
our entire life right right and as a
leader being self-aware i like what you
said about that knowing what we know and
don't know and
you know and then not you know not
holding ourselves to the standard that
we have to know everything
um i mean it's not possible really to do
everything well
so having that self-awareness of knowing
where our strengths lie and where
we need to backfill or hire to fill the
gaps
or maybe we do have to get stronger in
certain areas so
so what are some other thank you for
that gustavo what are some ways i mean
that's the question i get asked you know
how can i do this i
i'm not in a leadership role now what
can i do to
to as gustavo said be ready when that
comes
up um what are some how-to things that
you all think would work or that you've
used
i i'm i think a variation also what
needy mentioned is that well sometimes
you may not have a
you know a role model where you work
um or could could even be so unfortunate
of not having uh you know a role model
in the past
but then you can resort to good books as
well
as as a way to finding role models and
uh expanding um
the understanding of what it means to be
a good leader
yeah so that that helps
and and and then um
in my case i think i also use
the kind of negative role model in the
sense of
saying this is the kind of leader i
don't want to
be like for example from things that i
have experienced in the past and say
well if i get to be a leader this is not
the kind of leader i want to be
so that makes me think how can i be
you know a leader that is not like this
uh
and uh and and so there is
a lot of uh you know self evaluation
like you were saying trying to find
what are my weaknesses or what are areas
in which
i could get better and that gives me
like a north of things that i need to
learn or investigate
absolutely that that negative um role
model
is so key i mean i can think i think
that was probably the most powerful
thing in my
um leadership development there you know
i work for some really great people most
of them
think thankfully but um there were
things with each leader that
i said you know this doesn't serve me
well
as an employee that works for them and
the team well
and they do this really well and i don't
think they do this really well i still
respect them but um you know
making note of those issues and then
figuring out how can i
be better at this and we can't be better
at everything
but that's even if you have a
self-awareness you know that you're too
dangerous
in a certain area and you need to you
know relinquish
the reins to somebody else to handle
that for you so
reading good books is an excellent
suggestion for
how to become more aware of the skills
that you need and how to develop
those i i giving you some resources at
the end
by there are so many books out there but
i found a few resources and we'll talk
about them briefly in a minute
the other suggestion i want to leave the
group with is joining an
uh either an online or in person group
when covid's over
uh leadership groups going to
conferences
participating in dialogues like we're
having today
uh learning from others for what worked
well for them
how they how they polish their skills
built their competencies
informal networking even online
with other leaders to talk about you
know what was helpful for them
um and then um you know just informally
working with your colleagues to
build your own confidence and get
feedback you know one thing that hasn't
come up yet today that i want to say
is becoming a leader who
is not afraid of feedback
and regularly asks for feedback
is so key to developing that
self-awareness
and being able to make the change that
you need to make to serve your
your employees better so um anyway we've
covered a lot of topics here today
um i appreciate so much i know we had a
smaller group than normal but yeah i
think it worked very well and i
thank you all for being uh great
participants and you have
lots to share lots of good things to
share and so i very much value what you
say today and
and and thanks again for that um so
but the the takeaway here is i want to
hear from
each of you if if i could i think we got
started a few minutes late so if you
could just share one
thing that is your takeaway today either
a new thought
or something that you hadn't been
focused on before
or even an action item that you might
take
to move yourself forward
who would like to start
um if i can i think it was
very nice to have a small group uh also
to
hear the same thoughts being uh
resonated so
that helped uh so the interactivity was
nice and also
uh knowing sometimes you
you think about what you should be doing
but getting
an expert tell you that these are the
right things to do
that's i think the key takeaway for me
right so it's it's not like everything
was new but of course some points
uh sometimes we forget and we focus more
on few things
and this is good for looking at a
broader picture great
thank you for being part of this today
appreciate it
anyone else want to share their takeaway
yes so i think this was a great group
[Music]
i i heard things that i uh
very aligned with my my thoughts about
leadership
so it's nice to know that uh more people
uh think that way so
uh i'm glad to to have participated
in this this group today
and thank you for all you offered to the
group it's great
venetius or edwin
um yes i i think that um i feel
the same way as others have expressed
and
this kind of aligns with what you were
saying at the end like uh
trying to find opportunities
to talk with other people
that are more experienced in
in leadership roles or um like in our
case or
trying to get better at it so i think
that's enriching
um like uh by one hand it could be like
you hear
that maybe what you're doing um is
you're on the right
on the right path or maybe you get to
learn that some of the things that
uh you you were doing maybe wouldn't
work or maybe you you get to learn new
things
things that you you had not thought
about right so
for me some of the things that you put
on the slide of you know the list of
of of things that um you would expect
a leader should develop i i find that
it was new for me that i could
investigate that and
also having this experience of talking
with you all uh have been
enriching helpful so um
yeah okay well thank you for sharing
that and thanks for your participation
today
vinicius would you like to share your
take away
okay so one final slide um i'll leave
this up
i and you'll get a copy of this
presentation
um here are just there's a book
um here there is um an article from the
harvard business review the leading club
clever people um if you haven't read
daniel goldman's
working with emotional intelligence he's
written several books
on emotional intelligence um i think
that's really important
there are um there is a
ted talks um probably you're probably
familiar with those there's
the top 30 best on leadership which i
think are really
many of them are very interesting don't
miss the one
by um simon sinek which is the num the
first one
um on becoming an inspiring leader and
and cheryl sandberg who of course used
to be the
google ceo i think and then now facebook
or
i don't know if she's the current one of
facebook but
um and then um i also found an article
for those who are
looking to develop their soft skills for
technical people so
just a few of the very many resources
uh available and
okay well thank you all i appreciate um
having you here today and
and learning from you and getting your
insights
and um uh i wish you all the best in
your journey to become
uh better leaders or develop your
leadership skills
thank you thank you
thank you so much
[Music]
you